Here we go. It's episode one 75. And you know what? I don't know. I don't know.
I straight up don't know. I didn't record Monday because the world was on fire.
I didn't record Tuesday because the world was on fire.
I don't know if the world's still on fire, but it's Wednesday.
So I decided to do it because maybe people want to laugh. I don't know. I just,
I just don't know. Um, I do know that the world is,
is and it gets worse and worse by the day, man. I thought COVID was real.
You remember? COVID do you remember Corona virus?
Do you remember it? Coronavirus is getting real well,
it got real and it had nothing to do with Corona virus because uh,
people are riding and looting out there.
And part of me wants to be like don't ride or loot.
And part of me wants to be like, dude, I get it.
I keep thinking of that clip. That Tupac said when he's like,
you know, well,
when you're it's like opening the door and seeing a party and all the people are
in there throwing salamis and they all got food and they're having a party.
And I say, Hey, can we have some of the food?
And then everybody in the party says, Oh, we don't have any food.
I don't know what you're talking about. And he says, okay.
And then the next day you come by and say, Hey, can we please have food?
And we're singing. Can we have food? Can we please have food? And he say, Oh,
we can't, we don't even know what to talk about. There's no food here.
You come back a week later. It's not singing anymore. It's give us some food.
We want some food. And then they're like, well, we don't have food.
We don't know what you're talking about a year later, two years later,
you're going to be coming in and you're gonna be like, give me that food.
I keep thinking about that clip because people tried
Nealon and people didn't want to hear that.
There were a lot of drew breezes out there.
People tried Nealon and that didn't work.
Okay. So maybe then we don't need as many windows.
I don't know what the answer is, but I don't know what the answer is.
That's the thing. What I know is
I have no idea how much racism is in the world. I keep thinking. I know.
And then some other opens my eyes to it. I posted a thing.
Three or four days ago, two days ago, I don't know about black lives matter.
And I couldn't believe the comments that I thought maybe I should disable
comments on this. And I thought I had, I it. And I didn't.
And I can't believe the comments under it.
I can't believe the racist under there. And I can't believe it.
Cause I don't know. Cause I'm a white guy. I don't deal with this every day.
You know? And I guess that's what they say. That's privilege. But I had no idea,
man. I saw people all lives matter, man. It's racist to say black lives matter.
Are you kidding me? If you think that's racist,
put on a bunch of put on a vest with a bunch of hot pockets and go hiking, dude.
That is insane.
It's not look I say black lives matter. Someone says black lives matter.
And then someone else says all lives, Oh actually all lives matter. And then,
you know what I say? I like bacon.
As long as we're going to be saying that doesn't pertain to the last that we
said, I like bacon
also. It's the same thing. If you say black lives, that's the whole point, man.
It's the whole point.
And I'm sick of these telling people when they can and when they can't protest
like drew Brees. Yeah.
But you can't do it during the national Anthem because that's,
you're disrespecting the flag.
When would you like me to protest?
Excuse me? Can I protest? What the are you talking about?
That's not what protesting is. Protesting is on the protesting.
If you're doing it when you're not supposed to,
you're the little kid staying up at night after your parents told you not to.
You're protesting. You're not protested. If you're sitting at noon,
watching cartoons after your parents made you lunch,
that's a protest that's doing what you're supposed to protesting is sitting in
front of the TV with the squiggly lines in between the two channels on Skinemax
and try to see a tit for one minute. That is protesting with your ticket,
your hand that's dude, look,
all I'm saying is kneeling. Wasn't working it. Wasn't working
and I'm not condoning rioting and looting. I don't think that that's right.
I don't think you should be out there breaking windows and like that.
But what the do I know?
I can't imagine how mad and here's the thing. Everyone should be that mad.
You know, if some of us are up, then we're up.
If some of us get up, then we are up.
We're not good. If some of us are, dude,
if you have a family and one of your kids is going through some,
you're going through some as a family.
It's just amazing. The people too. It's hard to keep some friends even. I mean,
I see some friends out there posting that I'm just like, really, man,
this is what you're going to die on this Hill.
And it's hard too, because you want to be in the position where you're like,
you know what? I want people to have their opinions. This is what America is.
I want them to be able to express opinions and not be canceled because 40 people
are getting canceled a day. Remember Jimmy Fallon,
nobody even remembers that anymore. That was eight hours ago.
Drew breeze now because he said, what the? Uh, you know,
and I completely disagree with drew breeze. Like I just said,
protesting is only protesting if you're doing it when you're not supposed to.
Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, uh, Hadrian, breezeway.
We think about black people and black lives matter. Well,
I don't think they should be disrespecting the flag. Oh cool, man.
What the I'd have to do with anything. I like bacon.
I would love to be that interviewer. Ah, so, okay.
So you think nobody should disrespect the flag? Well,
did you know something about me? I like bacon.
I don't know, man. I don't know. I just, I don't know.
I don't know what it's like to walk down the street as a black guy or a black
woman. I don't know. And I won't ever know, uh,
you know, I didn't know how I wanted to start this podcast.
I didn't know if I wanted it to be serious or silly. I, you know,
I don't want to try and tell anybody what to do because I hate that.
The black, you know, the, the black square that people were posting.
I didn't do that. Uh, the, the, what was a blackout Tuesday or whatever,
God that was to me, it was like, yeah, everyone posted it.
All of a sudden I look at Instagram, everything's black. It's like, I'm blind.
I don't know what's going on. And then I look and I'm like, Oh,
you're supposed to post this in solidarity. Look who really gives a.
What you're posting on Instagram. Okay. I get it.
I posted a black lives matter thing because I wanted to show my people that
follow me, that I supported the movement and that's good, you know,
it's not bad. Um,
and then everyone started posting this black square and,
and hashtag black lives matter. And then, and then people were like,
you're gonna post the black guy plus the black square.
Otherwise you're piece of. And then we were like, and then everyone was like,
I don't know. And then before I even decided to post a black square and I,
people were like, well,
you up if you post a black square because you put black lives matter and it's
called of the feed. And now we don't know what the,
where to donate because we can't click the hashtag and see what a donut.
We can click the hashtag and see what's going on. Some cops are shooting at,
rubber bullets. We can't see it. We've got to click the hashtag.
We can't see it. So you up posting the black square. Okay. Then you know what?
Then my post is the black lives matter one. That was the last one I did.
And that was the one where these are out here trying to get you canceled.
Man puts a black, do it, do it, do it. You did it. You up, you up. You up.
A lot of it is about complying, which is weird as, man. Um,
like the, uh, the, um,
there was a clip now and I had it saved and they deleted it.
We're a bunch of white, white people were on the ground kneeling.
Um, w renouncing,
is that the right word there? Um,
white privilege there we'll look. I promise never to be privileged.
I promise to do as well as I can and lift up black people.
And it was like, dude, Hey, you white people.
That's that doesn't absolve. You,
you think it's that easy? That's white privilege.
You morons. Oh dude,
let's get together in a park and sing racism over.
No, dude, I want to protest against that protest.
You don't get to absolve yourself in a afternoon.
There's 500 years of slavery, whatever the it is.
And you think because you go into a park and you're like,
I'll lift up black people. I promise. And then you feel good about yourself.
You leave. And you're just like, cool. Well, I guess I'm going to heaven.
You're doing that for you.
And this is where I would be in a audience. And people would be like,
[inaudible],
this is getting real. Remember Corona virus,
man. Unbelievable
Tibor college was
it's so funny that some of these people just feel like they need to post
because it's a PR move to bore college.
Tibor college is committed to treating all people with respect because every
person on the face of the earth matters to God treating people as if they do
not matter misses the Mark that Jesus set for all of us,
especially those who are followers of him. We desire to be peace, salt,
and light in our world of violence, chaos, and evil.
We want to overcome evil with good and bring healing to brokenness our faith
in Jesus Christ empowers us to equip men and women to be instruments of peace,
justice, and healing.
We are taking actions that will help us live out this commitment to Christ his
kingdom and our society.
Several legis loaded in religion. Dude,
just say, first of all, well,
there's some evidence about these.
Look at this guy tweeted to, to poor college.
You threatened to every athlete that if they took a knee and peaceful protest,
they would be suspended. Okay. So then what side are you on a?
Come on, guys. Just shut the up. At this point, you,
you made your bed just stay sleeping.
It's like that. Leah Michelle girl, dude, I don't know her at all.
Have zero clue, even really who she is. But I found out that she's on glee.
You know, after the fact that glee was on and uh.
She was talking about what was the thing Lee and Michelle said
on Twitter, trying to look for it. Leah, Michelle.
Um, yeah,
find it can find it one fire.
He didn't show it to me.
Did you add it, dude? Can't find it. Great. Everyone's fired in the world.
Can't find a meat. Yes, dude. How do you spell Michelle? Yes.
One L not how you spell it. AIS got it.
She wrote George Floyd did not diverse deserve this.
This was not an isolated incident and a Mustang. Black lives matter, dude.
And somebody on glee took her to town. Dude.
She writes this girl's name is Sammy where I guess she was ugly to
Illumio. Remember when you made my first television gig,
tele television gig of living. Hell because I'll never forget.
I believe he told everyone what, if you had the opportunity,
you would in my wig amongst other traumatic microaggressions.
That made me question a career in Hollywood, uh, God,
and 486,000 likes.
How are you going to go say you're going to and black people's wigs and then say
black lives matter, obviously. Yay.
You don't think that Andy,
your Tibor college personified,
Somebody wrote,
I worked on glee and it was a known fact that Leah Michelle was a huge BITC.
H I don't say.
Not even a whispered thing on set. They outwardly resented her.
I'm glad others are now aware of this type of person. She is so sorry.
She's turned into, as you liked as a, I mean,
I don't know about any of this. I kind of heard stuff about her,
but after the fact,
so I don't know if I don't know anything about it, but that's crazy.
It's so weird that, and that gets it.
And then she lost her sponsorship with happy go lucky or whatever the it is.
Happy feed. I don't know what the she did.
Some skincare thing that was like called happy go-lucky happy feet or some,
or maybe it was a good living or eating healthy, whatever the it is. And,
and then, uh, but this was the one that I saw. That was amazing.
This was the one that I saw that was amazing.
Her name is Lauren loves veggies and is an annoying vegan.
Is that a double? Or is that a, what do you call it? A redundant dude. Vegans.
Aren't all annoying.
But if there's a high percentage of annoying people in veganism, of course,
and I retweeted it and this is what she said,
this needs to be said, here we go. Anytime somebody says,
this needs to be said, guess what? Guess what? It doesn't need to be said.
Okay. That's like saying that's like being someone who was like, trust me,
horns. Trust me.
Trust me.
Push Whoa, whoop,
whoop, whoop, whoop, whoop. Look what this girl said.
I feel like this needs to be said,
and I really wish that more people would connect these two dots,
but black lives matter and animal lives matter.
Thinking, thinking, thinking, dude,
that is absolutely grenade material. What node?
Hey, are you 11
quick question. Did you come out of your mommy eight years ago?
Hey,
don't ever say black people and animals in the same
sentence, unless you're saying, Hey, black people look out for those animals,
dude. Are you out of your mind? Hey,
who is your parents? Dude? I'm sorry, but like,
let's just listen to that a little bit.
More people would connect these two dots,
but black lives matter and animal lives matters.
Literally all sentient beings.
Oh dude. How about this?
Don't say Senti and beans to me.
Don't ever say sentience being stupid.
What are you? A robot?
Sentience beings deserve equal rights
from black people to animals, to flowers,
sentient beings. If I ever find out what an actual sentence would be,
I don't know what a number, what the umbrella is.
I've sent you and beings I've ever find that out. That's it.
I'm going to jump off a building. I don't want to know don't ever tell me.
What is sent to you in being is.
Deserve a life free fear,
free from abuse, free from unjust prosecution.
I just say chicken by the way.
No one, whether it's a human being,
especially ones with different colored skin than yours
and animals.
No one, no one,
including people with different skin and animals. No one,
no one. Whether it be, Oh, bird
zebra, no one also.
Preachers the news because of their time to die. They don't deserve to die.
That's killing black people and stop killing animals.
Doubled down and said it again.
Maybe she was hoping that since the first time she got canceled,
the second one would on cancel her.
Black lives matter movement with all the same.
Oops. Oops, oops.
All of it. And it's important. Each one of them is so individually important.
I really hope that people can start to connect the two.
I ate chicken. I ain't chicken, dude. I chicken and bacon today.
Oh. My friend just tweeted under her. This is gross and tone. Deaf and trash.
Be better. Think better. Read other books. Stop this. Well. Right.
Do dude read other books as a good wow man.
Hey, read other books. Spin. Move in.
You're out jumping through a window.
Wow. That's amazing, dude. How'd you blow them up? Having sex with a chick. Wow.
How'd you blow my back out that hard. Read other books. Sunglasses on
Freeze frame is you jump out the window. Um, anyway.